möglicherweise hat ein E-Auto das Feuer
auf dem Auto Frachter vor der
niederländischen Insel Ameland
verursacht und jetzt ist die Frage geht
von Elektroautos eine erhöhte
Brandgefahr aus darüber möchte ich jetzt
mit Anita Schmidt sprechen von der
Bundesanstalt für Materialforschung und
Prüfung Frau Schmidt schönen guten Tag
sie leiten dort den Bereich Sicherheit
von gefahrgutverpackungen und Batterien
Frau Schmidt eine norwegische Reederei
sagt jetzt sie nimmt keine E-Autos mehr
mit seit Anfang des Jahres
Versicherungen warnen gibt es denn
generell ein Sicherheitsproblem mit
E-Autos
im Vergleich von Elektroautos zu
Benzinern kann man ganz klar sagen und
es gibt keine größere Gefahr
hinsichtlich der
Energiedichte und das Energieinhalt ist
und wir schauen uns jetzt mal gemeinsam
ein Video an das zeigt wie eben so ein
Brand in einem E-Auto entstehen kann
der Akku eines E-Autos kann bei einem
Unfall oder Fabrikationsfehler in Brand
geraten er besteht aus ganz vielen
Modulen in diesem Modulen befinden sich
wiederum die einzelnen Batteriezellen
wenn eine von ihnen ein Defekt hat kann
sie sich stark erwärmen es entstehen
entzündliche Gase und so kann in einer
Kettenreaktion der Brand entstehen von
außen ist er mit Löschwasser schlecht zu
erreichen deshalb muss der Akku häufig
in einem Wasserbad lange runtergekühlt
werden
Frau Schmidt also das heißt das Vorgehen
ist ein komplett anderes als bei einem
Auto mit einem Verbrennermotor
im Jahr tatsächlich bei einem
Verbrennermotor also Benzin kann man
durch
Sauerstoffabschluss gut löschen das ist
bei Lithium Batterien nicht so die
können tatsächlich auch ohne Sauerstoff
von außen weiterbrennen
da ist die einzige Möglichkeit sie
runter zu kühlen und aber auch in dem
Moment wo man sie runtergekühlt hat ist
es nicht sicher dass in dem Moment wo
sich die Batterie wieder erwärmt das
nicht die verbliebenen können
und das heißt das ist im Prinzip mit
diesem Aquarium dass wir gesehen haben
der einzige Weg einen E-Auto zu löschen
gibt es auch noch andere Möglichkeiten
das was man tatsächlich im Moment sieht
was die Feuerwehr auch meistens tut ist
dass man eine defekte kritisch defekte
Batterie in eine in ein solches
Wasserbad eintaucht man erhält damit
zwei Effekte das eine ist man kühlt die
Batterie runter in dem Moment fangen die
noch übrigen Zellen nicht auch
anzubrennen und der zweite Punkt ist man
kann erreichen dass die Batterie langsam
entladen wird wir haben ja nicht nur
reines Wasser sondern wir haben auch
leitfähiges Wasser und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Aspekt zu wissen dass eine
Lithium Batterie die nur geringe Ladung
hat dass sie sehr viel weniger leicht
brennt als eine Batterie die voll
geladen ist
wir haben ja gestern zu dem Brand vor
Ameland mit ZDF heute live gestreamt
kann man sich auf Youtube oder in der
ZDF Mediathek auf ZDF heute die er
anschauen und da gab es in den Chats
eine heiße Diskussion zwischen den
Befürworter und den Gegnern von
Elektroautos würden sie jetzt insgesamt
sagen ein E-Auto ist gefährlicher als
eins mit verbrenner motor vor allem eben
in Bezug auf selbst Entzündung also
dieses Szenario was viele immer vor
Augen haben das Auto entzündet sich in
der Garage und steht dann in Flammen
es war auch sehr gut in dem Video zu
sehen das geht insbesondere darum dass
die speckbatterien anfangen zu brennen
wenn eine Zelle einen Defekt hat zum
Beispiel durch
dass sie beschädigt es mechanisch dass
sie überladen wurde dass sie zu heiß
geworden ist dass in dem Moment die
Batterien erst anfangen zu können
ansonsten ist die Batterietechnologie
eine sichere Technologie
bei der eben davon auszugehen ist dass
sie genauso sicher ist wie der Benziner
wie gesagt wenn es sich allerdings
unbeschädigte Batterien handelt in dem
Moment hat man natürlich andere Gefahren
mit denen man hier umgehen muss und zwar
ist das insbesondere dieses Brennen bei
sehr heißen Temperaturen man sieht dass
Teile von Zellen
rausgeschleudert werden können wir haben
die gefährlichen Brandblase von daher
hat man da einen Unterschied in der Art
und Weise des Engel des Energiespeichers
der dort verwendet wird ansonsten hat
natürlich ein Auto auch an sich eine
sehr hohe Brandlast und wenn ein Auto
brennt kann man sich vorstellen dass
wenn eben auch die Schaumstoffe der
Sitze wenn die brennt dass man auch da
sehr viel gefährliche Brandblase
entstehen lässt also das heißt eine
intakte Batterie ist ungefährlich eine
defekte Batterie ist dann schon eher ein
Problem und dazu kommen eben auch diese
ganzen Kunststoffe und Baustoffe die bei
einem Auto verbaut sind es gibt ja
mittlerweile ein Autohersteller der auch
so
Einfüllstutzen für Löschwasser einbaut
sind würde sowas helfen müsste sowas
generell verbaut werden
prinzipiell gibt es gute
Sicherheitslösungen wie man
Elektroautos sicher machen kann und da
ist die Forschung auch unterwegs ein
Einfüllstutzen für Wasser ist erstmal
möglicherweise nicht ausreichend dass
man genügend Wasser auch zur Verfügung
hat löschen
ansonsten gibt es eben andere
Möglichkeiten Batterien so zu entwickeln
dass wenn eine Zelle brennt dass er
nicht leicht alle anderen Zellen in dem
in der Batterie mit angezündet werden
dass wir also eine sogenannte
propagation nicht sehen wenn wir alleine
einzige Zelle im in der Batterie brennt
ist das noch nicht problematisch für die
Insassen und für die Umgebung das heißt
die Forschung geht ganz klar dahin die
Batterien an sich sicherer zu machen sei
es durch Kühlsysteme sei das durch
sogenannte hietzings auf der anderen
Seite ist man auch dahin unterwegs die
Zellen an sich selber sicherer zu machen
durch sichere Materialien
laut einer Studie der Allianz
Versicherung sinken zwar immer mehr
weniger Schiffe wir kommen noch mal kurz
auf die Schiffe zurück aber wenn es dann
Unfälle gab dann waren Brände eben die
Hauptursache und die Ursache dafür für
diese brennende sei eben der Transport
von
Elektrofahrzeugen und anderer
batteriebetriebener Güter welche
Maßnahmen braucht es aus ihrer Sicht
damit der transportsicherer wird also
wir reden ja mittlerweile nicht nur von
E-Autos Lithium-Ionen Akkus sind ja
mittlerweile vielfältig verbaut
ja tatsächlich der Transport von Lithium
Batterien an sich und nimmt bei den
Transportvorschriften einen großen
Rahmen ein da gibt es viele verschiedene
Vorschriften für von intakten Batterien
bis zu wie kann man defekte Batterien
transportieren für alles gibt es da
Möglichkeiten die werden auch im
Seeverkehr verwendet ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass man im Seeverkehr
ähnliche Regelungen umsetzen könnte wie
im Luftverkehr wo man nur Mädchen
Batterien transportieren darf die eine
geringe Ladung haben also die nicht voll
aufgeladen sind sondern nur bis zu 30 %
allerdings wird es natürlich schwierig
sein Privatfahrzeuge zu kontrollieren
dass man dort nur 30% Ladung haben
dürfte weil er Batterie
solche Möglichkeiten sind aber generell
da ähm dass man auf die Art und Weise
versucht die Regelwerke auf dem Schiff
doch noch etwas zu verbessern denn wir
haben da einfach die besonder Situation
man kann auf dem Schiff nicht einfach
diese großen ja platzmengen die
notwendig sind diese Abstände schaffen
um zu verhindern dass ein Brand von
einer Batterie sich auch die nächste
fortsetzt das ist eben das große Problem
auf dem Schiff dann ist der Zugriff auf
möglicherweise Container die ganz weit
unten stehen das ist natürlich
problematisch vielleicht haben einige
Schiffe gar keine Kräne an Bord
und Unterdeck transportieren ist
natürlich auch sehr problematisch und
daher könnte ich mir vorstellen dass in
Zukunft ist in der regelwerksentwicklung
in dem Bereich der Schifffahrt in solche
Richtung gehen könnte
sie verfolgen die Diskussion auch seit
gestern seitdem das Feuer auf diesem
Auto Frachter vor Ameland ausgebrochen
ist zumal man ja auch noch mal sagen
muss es steht noch nicht
hundertprozentig fest dass eben ein
E-Auto das Feuer verursacht hat wenn sie
sagen dass diese aktuelle Diskussionen
ein wenig zu weit geht im Moment die
Sicherheit von E-Autos insgesamt in
Frage zu stellen
ich denke dass die
Technologie der Elektroautos so weit
fortgeschritten ist dass wir die nicht
mehr in Frage stellen sollten es gibt da
tatsächlich so viele
Sicherheits Möglichkeiten und auch schon
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen die getroffen
sind in Fahrzeugen dass ich das nicht in
Frage stellen würde und gerade auch in
den Zusammenhang jetzt mit diesem Brand
erstens sagten schon wir wissen noch gar
nicht genau ob der Brand ausgelöst wurde
durch eine Auto mit einer
Lithium-Batterie es gibt sicherlich auch
ganz viele andere mögliche randquellen
auch einen Schiff ja und sicherlich wenn
erstmal ein Brand eben auf einem Schiff
ausgelöst wurde dann wenn natürlich die
Autos mit und natürlich auch die
Batterien würden wahrscheinlich einfach
mitbrennen
und vielleicht zum Schluss noch die
Frage weil wir sie als Expertin jetzt
gerade im Interview haben in ganz ganz
vielen Dingen sind ja mittlerweile
Lithium Akkus verbaut Handys E-Bikes und
so weiter was raten sie denn im Umgang
damit
so lange die Batterien unbeschädigt sind
[Musik]
denke ich ist der Umgang sehr sicher
damit in dem Moment wo man seine
Batterie beschädigt wie auch immer durch
einen Unfall zum Beispiel ist E-Bikes
in dem Moment sollte man ja vorsichtig
umgehen und achtsam sein und auf
Erhitzung
achten ob sich jetzt der Akku erwärmt
das sind die ersten Anzeichen wenn man
eine Ausgaben sieht dann ist das auch
das allererste Anzeichen dafür dass eine
Batterie sogenannte thermisch durchgeht
und in dem Moment sollte man ja sich
schleunigungssicherheit bringen
Frau Schmidt ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich für das Gespräch